cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Lou gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I want to pull up these
tweets from Mike cernovich talking about
what happens when we lose in 2024. now I
certainly think Mike is a bit
um what's the right word these tweets
are very very serious I believe they may
be a bit aggressive but I think the
spirit of them is correct now that I've
given you that warning you'll understand
when I read them for you
Mike turnovich tweeted
when we lose in 2024 I'll be hunted down
and murdered by the regime have already
had this talk with my family all these
goober conservatives think they'll be
okay they won't look up the Bolshevik
Revolution Y'all Gonna Be imprisoned and
you people have no clue
he was quote tweeting uh himself he said
in this tweet showing these older tweets
as I tend to be ahead year is usually on
subjects people attack me and then years
later copy my swag now I'll tell you the
future 2024's total defeat the RNC isn't
even running ads on X let alone doing
other voter registration at scale he
then said when we lose he'll be hunted
down and then he added this if you're a
conservative with a large platform have
you talked to your family about how
you're going to be framed for a crime to
be killed in 2024 if Biden wins if you
think this is hyperbole you have not
been paying attention 2024 is life or
death it's time to understand
well
I'm gonna just show you Elijah Shafer he
responded saying I've already begun
taking precautions I'm International for
a reason I find that uh to be a very
interesting response from Mr Schaefer
and uh while I do think Mike's tweets
may be a bit aggressive
it's not so people misunderstand these
conversations because their view of the
world is based on the movie and in
movies what happens is the evil dictator
Supreme Emperor takes power and then
appears in a in a ghastly image or the
hood and goes Execute Order 66 and then
all of a sudden all the good guys are
just purged from existence that's not
really how it happens
um which you need to understand about
this stuff is okay so uh Tech
entrepreneur in Baltimore was just
beaten to death raped and murdered in
her own home and the man who did it was
known to the police because only a few
days earlier he had beaten tortured and
raped a a woman in front of her her
boyfriend and then set them both on fire
I say these things because understand
that was for no reason
when Mike cernovich says when we lose
these things will happen perhaps
a bit aggressive as I stated because you
know we don't know the time frame for
kind of extremism will be
but there are several things you need to
understand one
we've got Chas chop already happening
we've got occupations already happening
around the country these things don't
happen overnight if you look to the
American Revolution the Boston Tea Party
and the Boston Massacre were years apart
Lexington Concord was 11 years at the
start of the revolutionary period the
bat like the actual start of the
Revolutionary War took 11 years from the
start of the period we determined to be
revolutionary you get Chas chop in a
matter of a couple years you have
autonomous zones we currently have stop
cop City right now in Georgia where
hundreds of people went out and staged
these acts of violence we have a hundred
people in Philadelphia ransacking stores
in total disregard for the law there are
that that's social breakdown and social
disorder
what what I think would happen in the
immediate is I'll just put it this way
Mike cernovich is not wrong I don't
think he'll be hunted down and murdered
I think he'll be Julian Assange
people like Mike cernovich who pose a
threat to the established order of the
military-industrial complex and the
neoconservative neolib military agenda
whatever you want to call it uh you'll
get Julian Assange meaning they're going
to accuse you like Russell Brand I would
not be surprised if Russell Brand ends
up getting convicted they've already
found Donald Trump civilly liable for
the most psychotic rape story imaginable
they've already ordered the dissolution
of Trump's companies and he's facing 91
indictments now that's Trump but people
keep saying this thing where it's like
I'll be okay well Aaron danielson's not
okay he took two to the chest he's no
longer around so
perhaps again a bit aggressive because I
don't know if it's effective messaging
to say they're going to kill you ah
they're screaming oh well look guys the
reality is dark days are in front of us
how long this period takes we don't know
I actually don't think we're facing
total defeat in 2024. I I disagree with
Mike on this I respect his opinion I
think he's very smart I think he does
see ahead better than most but I I do
see a a possibility for victory in 2024
especially now that RFK is running this
changes the game substantially but just
understand
even if Trump does win it doesn't mean
whatever is happening in this country
ends when you have far left extremists
storming government property firebombing
things when it is the norm for them to
go on social media and and threaten
people with death and the reason why we
bring the story up first is because the
next door we're talking about is the guy
who threatened to blow up Andy knows
speaking event was arrested so they're
they're still Law and Order you know a
little bit social order is breaking down
when you look at San Francisco when you
look at Philadelphia when you look at
Chicago New York these flash mobs all
over the place that shows social order
breakdown and understand this
what do you think the government does
when social order breaks down do you
think that the government will come
protect you when you are under attack by
violent mobs of Lawless Riders
look only to 2020 when in the there are
two big stories a woman was in her car
surrounded by rioters screaming and
banging on her card she called 9-1-1 and
they said what do you want us to do and
she goes they're attacking me what do I
do I have my daughter in the car and
they're like ma'am what do you want us
to do
good luck another guy in his apartment
said that people were fighting in his
Lobby and the riding was get there and
he was told sir the city is under attack
what would you have us do
I love the writing of the game Fallout
3. you guys I think you're all familiar
with it at this point I talk about it a
lot the so for those that are familiar
Fallout video game I know it's fiction
but it's it's written by humans who are
are looking at what happens around the
world and what they think may occur
the video game is about a nuclear
Annihilation nuclear war wipes out the
world and then everyone goes into vaults
simplified version the government
becomes something called The Enclave the
remnants of United States government and
you know what they do they they shoot
and kill you in the game and this is I
think correct writing on the part of the
game developers the US government will
seek to preserve itself and you are in
the way so when we begin seeing
non-citizens being shipped into Staten
Island what do the police do beat and
arrest the residents of Staten Island
they seek to preserve themselves by any
means necessary and you are in the way
so what Mike is saying and my concerns
are more so it's not that Biden will get
reelected and Order uh order the police
to Execute order 66. it's that they're
gonna say circle the wagons around
government and and
Destroy in any any way possible anyone
who threatens us
if you want to know what's going to
happen you can look to what happened in
the cultural revolution in China
there is ample examples of what happens
when the government has a a change of
what the fundamental principles that
government stands for means and the way
that the population reacts and the way
that the government reacts we saw in
2020 a whole lot of rioting and a whole
lot of stuff going on and the police
could not and maybe they could have but
they refused to do anything about it
I don't see any reason why if there is
some other type of civil unrest like
that how the police or the the
government would would behave any
different definitely you I would hope
that they would see the mistake they
made in 2020 by letting it get out of
hand but not stopping it on day two it
didn't get out of hand well to them they
got what they wanted in fact it worked
perfectly what I'm wondering is because
you're saying I think Tim mentioned it's
like a dissolution of order in the
system but what I definitely see is a
rise of organized crime in the system
these people that are organizing on
Facebook chats wherever signal they're
organizing flash mobs they're organizing
and it's like not one organization it's
a lot of little organizations but it's a
new type of organized crime that needs
to be dealt with and it's maybe that the
government doesn't know how to deal with
it quite yet I mean they got their spy
Tech but it's just so disparate it's
hard to see it coming you've got nine
poor kids in Philadelphia that want to
get on a signal chat and decide to go
break into a Best Buy at nine o'clock
like you can't how does the government
so so it might be that they are
unequipped it worst case scenario
they're they're complicit yeah that's
what happened that's what I fear the
most because if if the government Gets
behind organized crime then you're
looking at a cultural revolution that's
like what it is
um hopefully there they want to stop it
out as much as the citizens do and
they're just looking for a time and a
place yeah he he mentions the Bolshevik
in the Tweet you just mentioned the
cultural all of these have in common a
plan for different tiers in society
right so the average normal you know
normal person that's a problem would be
dealt with a lot differently right maybe
they just leave that to the flash mobs
maybe that they leave that to the
activists in the extremists
um but people like cernovich
and maybe even some of us you know I
mean seriously uh that would be
different you know the Julian Assange
treatment
lawfare when it can be done you know I
know people who um
have been indicted in Georgia we're this
close to being indicted in Georgia uh so
they're there but I guess that that
matters what role are you playing and
how influential are you and opposing
something that they don't like I do just
want to bring up this 2024's total
defeat I don't know if he's using
reverse psychology there or what but
he's right about the RNC not doing
enough so as a pollster I look at this
and I say they're indicting Trump
because he is
improve so much with certain groups that
Republicans are not supposed to win they
know that and they're looking at that
and they're saying what up what other
choice do I have I might as well because
if this man gets back in it may be me on
the Block
um still
the RNC is way behind in infrastructure
they should have done much better in 22
and didn't because they still don't
really understand what they're up
against
and even watching because I I know about
this even watching some of them trying
to get it together and trying to deal
with ballot harvesting uh it's a messiah
complex on the right everyone wants to
be the hero they're not working together
like Democrats work together well I
highlighted this in a segment where I
was talking about Democrats going full
communist because they're cheering for
the ruling against Trump's businesses
where the judge basically banged the
gavel summary judgment no more Trump
organization and I showed this voting uh
chart
of the social scale and the economic
scale Trump's voters are anti-woke but
spread out between the left and the
right Trump even has Communists to
support him like I don't mean like um
the ideological Communists of the woke I
mean people who believe in very far left
Progressive economic systems of
government control
they are he has very few actually
laissez-faire capitalists interestingly
but they're very it's it's the cluster
is in the center doesn't surprise me the
Democrat block is clustered entirely in
the far left Social and economic area
which means they mostly just March in
lockstep not completely there there are
Democrats reaching up into the less woke
area but the cluster may be the
plurality large Pro or majority is all
hyper concentrated in one Circle Ultra
woke as far left as possible in both
economic and social again Trump's base
was anti-woke opposing the social left
but spread out economic in terms of
Economic Policy which explains shows
like this thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time